crypto is amazing you can make a lot of
money in crypto for sure but it can also
be many people's downfall this is
because you can make so much money in
crypto and this is what the young kids
are doing 18-year-olds are becoming
multi-millionaires just because of
crypto but because they're so young and
they don't have any life experience they
lose it all and now they don't have any
work ethic they have no Drive within
them to go out every day start working
and build a business they don't want to
take a job for $3,000 a month mentally
how can you do that when you were
literally just worth $10 million like
the other month how can you bring
yourself to hustle to grind to build a
business and so what I'm saying is yeah
crypto is great if you can keep the
money but a lot of these kids they don't
keep the money the pump destroys their
work ethic they have no skills and no
life experiences so they're just not
ready to build a business or go back to
work so what do they do they wait for
the next pump and they literally become
gamblers trying to chase that next pump